porque se deshicieron los acuerdos de
hace dos días que prometían el fin de
las protestas y en que van ahora las
negociaciones con los gremios
y muchas gracias a nosotros que como
parte del gobierno del presidente
cortito mantenemos la puerta del diálogo
como alternativa eficiente y efectiva
para salir de esta situación hay tres
temas que han sido
reclamados
básicamente el área del combustible que
es algo que aunque sea por razones
externas panamá está afectándonos a
todos en nuestro país al igual que el
resto del mundo tenemos también el costo
de los alimentos y el el costo de la
vida y finalmente el costo de los
medicamentos el domingo se hizo un
anuncio de parte del vicepresidente de
la república josé gabriel carrillo en el
cual llegamos a un acuerdo de congelar
el precio de combustible en 3 balboas
con 25 centavos 3 dólares con 25
centavos el galón de combustible tanto
el diésel como de gasolina
esto fue efectivamente realizado desde
ayer a las 3 de la tarde el presidente
cortizo reúne a su gabinete en una
reunión extraordinaria y se aprueban los
tres válvulas con 25 centavos con lo
cual esperamos que en la intensidad de
la protesta y del malestar que hemos
estado viendo se reduzca y que volvamos
al diálogo nacional si pese a todo ello
pese a los subsidios de los que usted ha
hablado los manifestantes alegan que a
pesar también de la pandemia y de la
invasión de ucrania el gobierno no ha
hecho lo suficiente le ha faltado
abordar las necesidades del país
ustedes como evalúan la respuesta a la
crisis
bueno a ello hay un planteamiento
político y es normal lo entendemos lo
respetamos nosotros como gobierno desde
que inicia la crisis del cúbito
iniciamos un programa que se llama
panamá solidario en el cual hemos
entregado más de 11 millones de bolsas
de alimento a lo largo y ancho del país
también hemos estado apoyando
de un baile digital que es un crédito
que se ha puesto en la identificación de
los panameños y panameñas de 120 balboa
dólares perdón al mes con lo cual se
pueden comprar alimentos y medicinas
aquí hay un componente político vuelvo y
repito lo entendemos sin embargo
consideramos que en este momento no hay
ninguna justificación para mantener los
cierres de calle hay un llamado que ha
hecho la iglesia católica para reunirnos
nuevamente y nosotros como gobierno
estamos dispuestos a seguir abordando
estos temas entendiendo que el costo de
la vida y el costo de los alimentos es
algo que nos preocupa y estamos seguros
que a través del diálogo vamos a llegar
a la mejor solución posible